This is again an eye tracking study. The
darker colors... so the closer you get to
red is where there's more attention on
the region of interest. So what you'll
notice here is there's various attention.
What's really curious to me about
this picture is... my adviser Phil
Zimbardo always taught me to be my
own first subject always.
So I always run myself as my first subject.
And I always end up being an outlier
and completely not instructive for other people.
So when I looked at this study the thing I
fixated on was the gun.
And you know like nobody's paying attention to the gun.
It's really sort of interesting. But you'll see differential attention so
What the Conservatives are paying
attention to are
the emblems of authority.
The patch is about: "I'm a cop," right?
Like, I'm the Law & Order.
Whereas what liberals are paying attention to
is the person getting the beat down.
And to a certain degree, liberals are also paying attention--
(I didn't Circle it) but, to the cane.
This is a disabled person.
Not a single conservative paid any
attention at all to the cane.
So there's real differences in what people
are paying attention to. It's not, again,
just an issue of interpretation.
It's an issue of perception.
Why is this important?
This is important because it can predict
important political choices that people make.
About policy issues.
So in the image that I just showed you, which is
this same image, you can actually look at how
liberals and conservatives respond differently.
And then the other thing we
manipulated was the story we told.
There was a 30-second narrative.
So in some of the narratives we called it a beat down.
And in some of the other narratives we
called it an arrest. And you'll notice
conservatives don't change at all
how they look at the image based on the narration.
But liberals completely change the way
that they think about it
when you call it a beat down versus an arrest.
Why is this important? Because different people
respond to different stimuli differently.
So in other words some people are much more visual
and some people are much more auditory.
Here you see in this particular instance that
the reactivity on that, the auditory reactivity, is liberal.
In this which is a different image of a woman
looking at a coffin. Where we said he died in combat,
versus he was a looter. You'll see that the difference
in perception changes as a function
of somebody being conservative.
Again these are things that you can run
not just with liberals and conservatives, but with other
categorizations as well.
When we run these with men versus women,
they're always really funny because
the men never pay attention to the narration.
It's all about the, it's all about the image.
But in these it's reactive based on whether or not
people are liberal or conservative
and how they look at the image.
Similarly in the sex differences one we had an image
you saw the one with Madonna and Britney Spears.
You can see the amount of time they
spend looking at the necklace.
In the other one, it's a picture of a soldier
holding an injured child. And you can look at differences
(here I want to show you how you can
divide it up by sex differences)
There's differences in men and women
looking at the child's face
versus the child's body.
So these aren't just ideological things.
You can also look at sex differences as well.
Although we've been primarily interested in the
ideological differences.
Again these help you predict policy preferences:
so we have people look at certain images
and then find out [ask people]
"Did we make a mistake sending troops into Iraq?"
Or "Do you think--" this was done a little while ago
"Do you think the US can or will win the war in Iraq?"
And you can predict people's response
to that policy question based on
how much time they spend looking at particular
parts of the image. So if they're spending a lot of
attention looking at the flag you can
see that that predicts their answer to
whether or not they think that the US
made a mistake in entering the war in
Iraq and so on and we've done numerous
ones of these about forty of them and
their end up being pretty consistent so
there are particular categories of
things that people care about and you
can look at this again by liberal or
conservative here I'm just listing
some of the Apes some of the Preferences
of people that are particularly
concerned with protection which on
average tend to be people on the right
of the political spectrum
none of these constellations should
surprise people who for example have
been watching the Republican National
Convention so what does this have to do
with genes there was a report a while
ago liberals you know research is
finding the liberal gene that is beyond
ridiculous right why is it ridiculous
it's ridiculous for several important
reasons first most importantly there is
no such thing right why is there no such
thing why can there never be any such
thing because genes aren't that simple
there are multiple genes there are
multiple pathways these things are
multifactorial
they work in complicated interaction
with environmental factors so you're
never gonna find one single thing that's
gonna help you understand the liberal
gene or the conservative gene these
things are very complex and it's not
just Physiology it's not just genetics
but it's also not just environment they
work together what does that mean it
means that DNA isn't your destiny genes
contribute to these political outcomes
but they're not the only thing that
matters the environmental factors also
matter quite a bit
you